hey guys welcome back to branding video
we're back on for honoring it and today
we have some tons of info to talk about
today about the outlines of what the
characters will look like as well as the
roadmap for 2019 year of the Harbinger
now let's get straight into it but I do
want to first off what I do want to
clarify is that I will actually be
showing the images this time because
these are from the ubisoft actual
website meaning that they are okay with
us talking about this so i will be
showing the video and stuff in the
photos and stuff on screen so you don't
need to go into the description and
click a link although i will provide
links if you do want to search it for
yourself but there will be on screen a
few if you guys don't want to do that so
the first photo is the year of the
Harbinger 2019 content roadmap I was
under the impression that the year of
the Harbinger was actually gonna be
season 9 of the name but I believe
that's what the whole year is gonna be
called season 1 is gonna be called Vorta
ger and the Knights are gonna get the
first hero on January 31st I believe
that is when it starts according to the
map
so in January 31st season 1 of 2019 the
Knights will be getting the first hero
which is what we talked about in last
video is not gender lock so you can be
male or female or on April or May season
2 will be coming up and the samurai will
get the hero and that that character is
going to be living the X season 3 is
gonna be in July and August and that is
going to be the Viking hero with the big
hammer that we talked about as well in
last video and in November to October is
season 4 and that is going to be the
wolven hero all four of these characters
are not gender locks so you can do male
or female whatever you want to do and
the weapons for the corresponding heroes
I was guessing correctly the woman is
going to be using the sword the hammer
belongs to the Vikings the double headed
axis to the samurai and the sword and
shield is for the Knights also midway
through some of this every single season
is going to have a seasonal event in
between each of the seasons nothing
nothing specific on what that is going
to be and in October there's going to be
another special Halloween event so it
might be year three of Feast of the
Otherworld very excited for that and on
top of that there's going to be ongoing
improvements including balance new maps
and more coming to the game as well
throughout this whole year so very
exciting news coming out with this whole
year of content and then the next image
is going to be the background it is
going to be the outline or the
background of what the heroes are
supposed to look like judging from this
photo the knight is going to have some
decent armor some big-ass Paul Jones or
shoulder pads
the woman is going to look like your
typical samurai guy would be the Viking
looks like he's not going to be beefed
up in armor as much but he does seem to
probably going to be a little bit on the
older side probably a older warlord type
character or a big Lord guy and the
samurai I can't really judge from this
image but he doesn't look as big and
Brawley as what I would expect so these
characters aren't going to be heavy big
but they are going to be new characters
and they are I'm assuming just based off
the weapons these guys will be heavies
and vanguards so this is very exciting
news so you have a whole lots of content
coming in with 2019 just a quick recap
just in case you were lost I did speak a
little bit quick I do apologize you
season one is gonna be happening around
January that's going to be the night
hero season 2 is gonna be between April
and May with a samurai season 3 is going
to be the Viking hero between July and
August and October and November is gonna
be around season 4 with the Wulin hero
and remember all four of these
characters will not be gender locked so
you can have male or female whatever you
want to use a completely up to your
preference with some seasonal events in
between all of these seasons as well
with a Halloween event coming in October
so lots of cool things coming within 20
1904 honor and of course the ongoing
improvements including balance new maps
and more which will most likely point to
rework so I'm excited my personal
opinion I believe that since we're only
going to be getting one hero per season
that also means we're going to be
getting one rework so once one hero and
one rework my personal opinion I think
it's going to be Shu Gopi is gonna be
first fall then maybe Lovering or Raider
and then whoever didn't get picked that
season is gonna be followed but the next
season stuff like that so my thoughts
are is it's gonna be one rework in one
hero per season throughout the entire
year which would be really nice because
that would help though the players that
do not like the new heroes but it would
also help the players that just need
some new fresh content in the game to
play some new people because it's gonna
be the end of the visit I hopefully you
guys did enjoy I'm very excited for your
harbinger let me know what you guys
think about that as always you can check
the links in the description if you do
want to see it for yourself or just play
back the video if you do want to look at
the image and soak it all in soak up all
that juiciness yeah
shout out to Ubisoft for actually
posting this and not and me not having
to find leaks and whatnot so that's
beautiful
yeah like the view if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side of foreign or that
being balance changes hero updates patch
notes leaks all this stuff about foreign
or all the information to kept everybody
up to date on what's happening in the
world of for honor the most recent
videos will be
screen if you guys do want to check that
out when I guys hope ever girls today
thanks for watching the video and peace
out
[Music]